what's popping my dark nights it's me Mt
and welcome back to the heavy spoiler
show Batman mask of the fantasm is an
absolute classic of a Batman movie that
is regularly talked about in
conversations centered around the
greatest Batman movies of all freaking
time so I was amped when I got the
go-ahead from Paul to make this
particular classic breakdown for all of
you guys because it is truly a Timeless
story that captures the raw emotional
pain that stems from the consequences of
Batman's vow to be the lon Dark Avenger
of Gotham's innocent people so throw on
your bat costume and or ski mask that
you bought from Target and let's punch
into this thing but before we do I just
want you guys to know that every like
that our videos get helped Paul and I
with our tireless careers of making
breakdowns by day and fighting Street
crime and wild coyotes by night because
those coyotes be up to no good so if you
guys could take a quick second and just
drop a quick like on this video that
would be super appreciated and make us
happy on the inside and we are hit with
a really cool Easter egg pretty much
right off the bat as soon as the movie
opens with the theme music for the film
as composed by Shirley Walker the very
same composer for the Batman animated
series but what's dope about this Latin
singing choir at the beginning is that
this choir isn't actually singing
mysterious Latin lyrics at all in fact
the lyrics of this theme are completely
made up nonsense well sort of according
to Shirley Walker herself the lyrics of
this opening are actually the names of
key orchestrators and singers of the
movies music team sung backwards as
Walker wanted to make sure that all of
those talented artists were given their
well-deserved time in the sun in her own
creative way and some examples that
Walker gave were Zed naner iob which
backwards translates to Bobby Hernandez
one of the choir members and onali M
which is the name of the music editor
Tom Milano backwards composing Legend
Han Zimmer also gets a shout out in this
intro as he was very good friends with
composer Shirley Walker in fact
according to co-director Bruce Tim all
of the synthesizing and organs in the
opening were all done by Han Zimmer
himself making this the very first
Batman project that Zimmer would work on
before his iconic work on Christopher
Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy over a
decade later and technically this is the
second Batman movie that Zimmer would
score where Batman faces off against a
former love interest as that of course
happens in The Dark Night Rises and to
make sure that her caringly creative
accreditation wasn't rejected by Warner
Brothers if they ever found out Walker
also made sure to include the names of
the film's directors producers and a few
Warner Executives as well so needless to
say Shirley Walker was an absolute queen
of kindness and a queen who
unfortunately passed away in 2006 at the
age of 61 so y'all better make sure to
pour one out for a cinema Legend Tonight
I know I will rest in peace Shirley
Walker I love you and your music and
honestly I truly don't blame Walker for
feeling the need to make sure that her
team had that kind of credit given
because this entire production had less
than a year to prepare this movie for
theatrical release as the crew was
initially told that mask of the fantasm
was supposed to be a straight to VHS
Affair despite the making of an animated
movie usually taking a couple of years
to actually complete the Productions
still managed to convert all of their
animations from television's 4x3 aspect
ratio to theatrical widescreen on time
because let's face it animator's
freaking rule man but unfortunately this
movie would end up proving to be a
theatri electrical flop for Warner as
mask of the fantasm would only make $5.6
million back at the box office after a
$6 million budget it would only really
be until the movie would release on VHS
and DVD that it would end up Crossing
that threshold of becoming profitable
but anyways the movie begins with a shot
of a casino called the Shady Lady which
I feel was definitely a nod to the
movie's main villain The fantasm Who
themselves is a very shady lady so shady
that she was modeled after the fictional
Grim Reaper as well well as the Batman
villain the reaper who was first
introduced in the pages of 1971's Batman
237 there are also very clear influences
from the Ghost of Christmas Yet to Come
From Charles Dickens at Christmas Carol
a classy creepy character that the Joker
references directly later on in the film
all of these characterizations are
extremely fitting for a phantom who
haunts the ultra greedy of Gotham City
with her first victim of course being
the very owner of the Shady Lady Casino
Chucky Saul as played by actor Dick
Miller an actor who was also murdered by
the Terminator and Terminator one but
anyways after Batman crashes into Chucky
s's operation and beats up his goons one
of those goons trapped under the table
tries to foolishly go for their gun
before Batman compromises his
Consciousness by kicking some Ikea into
his Cranium which was a great and subtle
way to establish Batman's overall
distaste for guns for those who are
being exposed to the character for the
first time through this movie but
considering what happens directly after
this with Chuck K saww losing his life
to Andrea bont's quest for bloody
Vengeance as a different kind of dark
angel of the night seeing Batman's
overall rejection of guns and killing
like that very much serve to show just
how much these two very Kindred Spirits
have let the trauma of their parents
death put them on similar but ultimately
radically differing paths Andrea bont is
of course voiced By Dana Delany who went
on to become the voice actress for Lois
Lane in the Superman animated series
after proving her chops in this movie so
basically um Batman and Superman have
the same girl Dana Delaney actually got
this job because she was very good
friends with Harley Quinn voice actress
Arlene sorin and the character of Andrea
Bowmont was actually named after Andrea
Romano who was the voice casting
director for the Batman animated series
at the time and the character was
apparently modeled after 1940s American
actress Lauren Ball but anyways after
Andrea murders Chucky Saul as the
fantasm we see her on a plane calling
her her City councelor boyfriend while
simultaneously staring at her
ex-boyfriend Bruce Wayne on the cover of
a Fortune Magazine which is of course a
famous business magazine in real life in
the following scene that brings us to
one of Bruce Wayne's fancy parties in
Wayne Manor we see three women hitting
on The elusive billionaire with the last
girl who can't spell for actually
being voiced by Arlene sorin the
original voice of Harley Quinn in the
Batman animated series sorin was
actually good friends with Andrea
Bowmont actress Delaney and was actually
the one who got her involved in this
film and the DC Animated Universe in
general so thank you Arlene sorin rip we
miss you then of course a fourth angry
redhead throws her drink in Bruce
Wayne's face and laments about how flaky
Bruce always is when it comes to making
commitments but while watching this
scene I definitely noticed that Bruce
Wayne's trauma has definitely given this
mentally ill- massed man a very specific
type that he's attracted to specifically
redheaded women that remind him of his
dead mother Martha Wayne which is why I
believe Bruce heads directly to that
framed picture of his dead parents
directly after being reminded of his
deep need for intimate and meaningful
affection from a red-headed woman and
yes at the risk of sounding like Sigman
Frey it seems clear to me that Bruce is
very much looking for an emotional
replacement for the first and most
influential nurturing womanly figure in
his life and the red-headed Andrea
Bowmont seems very purposefully designed
after Martha Wayne even as far as
wearing the same exact type of earrings
as her when they were dating by being in
that relationship Bruce Wayne was trying
to recapture the spirit of his parents
loving relationship by replicating it
with Andrea as Bruce himself of course
looked a lot like his own father Thomas
Wayne so for a while there when he
allowed himself to be happy with Andrea
Bruce didn't feel the sting of the loss
of his parents as much because he could
literally see them reflected in his own
relationship like every time he looked
in the mirror with his girlfriend he
could see his parents so he was happy
however the guilt that Bruce experiences
for wanting to abandon his plans for
vigilante justice in order to live a
happy life with Andrea comes out in full
force later on as he tearfully asks for
his dead parents' permission to be free
of the promise that he made to keep
Gotham safe from the same types of
people that took their lives like I
truly love that moment so so much
because it is a perfect encapsulation of
Bruce Wayne's mental illness he
literally feels like his dead parents
would judge him if he were to ever stop
being Batman which is insane like all
Thomas and Martha Wayne would want for
Bruce was for him to be happy and Alfred
knows this which is why Alfred later
reacts in shock and dismay when Bruce
puts on the Batman mask for the very
first time because Alfred is seeing
Bruce throw his life away but anyways
that specific scene of Bruce in front of
his parents' grave was one of Kevin
Conroy's favorite scenes of all time as
the character Batman because of how
vulnerable and emotionally open Bruce
Wayne becomes in in his emotional
conflict but anyways we then get a
flashback to Bruce talking to his dead
parents right before meeting Andrea
Bowmont for the very first time who was
having a very Lively chat with her own
dead mother and hey random fact but
Thomas and Martha Wayne's Graves were
actually redesigned for this movie for
some reason as this grave looks a lot
differently from when we first see it in
the nothing to fear episode from season
1 of the Animated Series but anyways
after this the day turns to night and
Bruce Wayne goes on his first night of
crime fighting a knight that would lead
him to confronting a group of Thieves in
nothing but a ski mask and a utility
belt full of throwing stars before
almost being arrested by Gotham PD this
differs drastically from Batman's first
night out in the comics as Frank
Miller's Batman year One series from
1987 has Bruce's first act as a
vigilante occur in the East End of
Gotham City while trying to save a
prostitute named Holly Robinson from
being abused by her pimp an event that
would lead a disguised and handcuffed
Bruce Wayne in the back of a cop car to
crash said cop car in order to escape
however though both these two events
differ both these tellings of Batman's
first night out cause Bruce to grow
frustrated with not being feared by bad
guys when he arrives on the scene which
then of course eventually leads him to
adopt the bat theme in order for fear
and dread to mentally his
enemies upon arrival however the
influence from the Batman year One
Comics is most prevalent later on in the
movie after South valestra is blown up
by the Joker and Batman is being a
aggressively chased by Gotham PD Special
Forces as year one Batman from the
comics had that exact same kind of heat
on his back following a building
explosion of his own but anyways after
Bruce Wayne narrowly escapes after his
first night on the streets he reads a
newspaper article of what happened the
very next day with one of the newspaper
headlines reading romsky depress I'm
innocent which is a fun little Easter
egg pointing to co-director and Batman
the Animated Series co-creator Eric
romsky Andrea the woman who only met
Bruce one time then surprises Bruce at
his home and the two get down to
business pretty much immediately because
let's face it your boy Bruce just got it
like that you know what I'm saying but
actually a really funny and fun fact
about this moment from Eric romsky
himself is that this is actually the
very first time Bruce Wayne ever gets
laid meaning that Bruce Wayne's first
orgasm went to the fantasm and speaking
of the fantasm Persona another fun fact
for you guys the name fantasm is never
actually said one time time during the
course of this movie like Andrea never
actually gives her darker Persona a name
at any point like if the title of the
movie wasn't Batman mask of the fantasm
we would literally have no idea what to
call this woman which is even crazier if
you consider that for the longest time
during production the name of this movie
was originally just going to be called
Batman masks without any mention of the
fantasm at all but anyways after this we
get the scene where the fantasm brutally
murders their second victim buzz bronsky
by crushing him with an angel statue
after he falls into an open grave hole
Not only was the statue murder symbolic
of this Angel of Death taking another
life but it also points again to the
Ghost of Christmas Yet to Come From A
Christmas Carol who famously brings
Ebenezer Scrooge to his own grave by the
end of his nightmare but an interesting
fact about this scene though in order
for this film to maintain its PG rating
the directors had to remove the brutal
bone crushing sounds of brony's death as
both Eric radomsky and Bruce Tim both
thought it made the moment a little bit
too brutal for the children but anyways
moving on later when Batman is spying on
Andrea's date with City councelor
douchebag Arthur Reeves he uses his Bat
oculars to read their lips in order to
decipher what they're saying to each
other something that Batman mask of the
fantasm sequence director Dan rebba
States was inspired by 2001 A Space
Odyssey in particular the scene where
Hal reads the lips of the dudes plotting
to shut him down this then leads to a
flashback to Bruce and Andrea's own date
to Gotham's world of the future Fair
which drew a ton of inspiration from the
New York World's fairs of 1939 and 1964
with the planet and Rocket structures in
the middle of Gotham's future fair being
modeled after the tylon and perisphere
theme center from the 1939 New York
World's Fair writer Paul Dei was
inspired to create the Gotham's world of
the future fair for the movie after he
and Bruce Tim drove past some very
spooky ass remnants from the 1964 New
York world Fair a few years prior like
Paul De very much intended for the
Gotham's world of the future fair to be
symbolic of Bruce and Andrea's idealized
future together in a beautiful and
peaceful Gotham City a future that they
both never actually got to spend
together which is why the run down in
abandoned Park served as an extremely
fitting setting for Bruce and Andrea to
have their conversation about vengeance
and what Vengeance could ultimately
solve in the end because both Bruce and
Andrea's own personal Quests for
vengeance have robbed them of their
ideal realized future so the destruction
of the park by the end of the film is
very much meant to represent any hopes
of them Ever Getting Back Together going
up in smoke but although they don't get
to experience it together we do know
that Bruce Wayne and Andrea bont do end
up seeing the Gotham of tomorrow when
they get older as Bruce of course goes
on to train the next Batman Terry
mcginness and Batman Beyond and an older
Andrea Bon is last seen stalking a young
Terry mcguinness's family after being
hired by Amanda Waller to Rob this young
Terry of both of his parents much like
Joe Chill took Batman's parents in order
for that trauma to forge Terry mcginness
into Batman but this older fantasm
rejects this job out of respect for
Bruce's own trauma this happens in
season 2 episode 13 of Justice League
Unlimited but the dopest part of Bruce
and Andrea's date is finding out that it
gave Bruce the inspiration for the
design of his sleek and iconic Batmobile
a Batmobile design that has yet to be
topped after all of these years because
if you're going to fight crime you might
as well do it in future futuristic style
but anyways after their date Andrea
introduces Bruce to her father Carl
Bowmont as voiced by actor Stacy ke who
also voiced the fantasms deep voice
throughout the movie this was purposely
done to throw the audience off of Andrea
Bowman scent by having the viewer assume
that it was actually Carl behind the
mask the whole time especially since the
fantasm character was very much inspired
by the reaper character from the Batman
comics whose secret identity was Judson
Caspian the father of one of Bruce
Wayne's Old Flames Rachel Caspian so
since Andrea bont is essentially this
universe's version of Rachel Caspian
tricking the audience to thinking that
they were going to see a similar
adaptation of the reaper from the comics
was a very clever move but anyways later
on when City councilor Arthur Reeves
hops into Sal vester's limo s asks
Arthur if he is a comedian which is some
excellent foreshadowing for S ultimately
being killed by Gotham's favorite
comedian later on in the film and fun
fact Sal's death is actually the very
first time the Joker's toxin has been
shown to actually kill somebody because
in the Animated Series up until that
point Joker's toxin was merely shown to
cause his victims to laugh
uncontrollably with a creepy ass smile
on their face with Batman being able to
calm most of them down with a special
antidote that he's developed after his
numerous encounters with the joker
however because the movie had a much
wider theatrical release outside of
normal children's television Batman mask
of the fantasm was allowed to do stuff
that the Batman animated series couldn't
do like you know showing blood showing
punches Landing making crude jokes and
doing some light but very brutal killing
like showing the corpse of an old man
who laughed himself to death after the
Joker switched out his oxygen tank for
that goofy giggle gas absolutely pranked
and it wouldn't really be until 1997's
new Batman adventures that the Joker
toxin would actually start killing
people regularly the way that God
intended The Joker would of course go
after councilman Arthur Reeves after
killing valestra exposing him to the
same Joker toxin that took vra's life
but while Arthur was able to survive
exposure to the Joker venom his mind and
face were permanently altered by the
experience as the Batman and Robin
Adventures annual from 1996 shows us
that the toxin would leave a joker esque
smile on Arthur ree's face and because
that toxin also made him crazy he would
eventually track down Andrea Bowmont and
try to kill her for ruining his
political career but Arthur Reeves would
unfortunately fall to his death after
trying to enact that Revenge but more on
that specific comic book later because
that book also fills us in on how
exactly the Joker survived after
disappearing with Andrea at the end of
the movie but anyways when we get the
flashback to Bruce and Andrea's
engagement we see that this is the first
moment that Bruce also discovers the
existence of the Batcave under Wayne
Manor which Bruce goes exploring in
later on in the film right before Alfred
delivers Bruce his wife wife rejection
letter like this event actually happens
a lot differently in the comics as
Detective Comics 205 from 1954 details
how Bruce Wayne originally found the
Batcave after suddenly plummeting into
it when the wooden floor of his barn
gave way to the weight of his big ass
muscles and later when Arty and Andrea
get back to Andrea's place after their
date Andrea rejects his sexy time
advances by claiming that she has a
killer day tomorrow which is hilarious
considering that she is literally a
killer and she does have a killer day
tomorrow so technically she did not lie
and honesty is super important in any
serial killer relationship but Andrea
would unfortunately lie straight out of
her teeth immediately after this when
she tells an intruding Batman that the
only person in her bedroom controlled by
their parents is him in response to
Batman asking her if she's still taking
orders from her father but we would
learn later that this is untrue as
Andrea herself became the fantasm in
response to her own parental trauma
because little does Batman know Andrea's
father Carl was killed by none other
than the joker as this movie of course
reveals that the Joker used to work as a
Hitman for the mobster Sal valestra
before he became Gotham's craziest clown
Prince of Crime Joker's inclusion in
this movie was actually requested from
Warner Brothers Executives who wanted
theater audiences to see Batman face off
against a familiar villain by the end of
the movie because while they really like
the fantasm as a villain they wanted to
make sure that their audience got their
money's worth because the fantasm wasn't
exactly tested yet however the directors
of the film chose to Omit Harley Quinn
for the movie because they wanted the
Joker to be the singular figure of chaos
throughout the film for both Andrea and
Bruce to chase as the Joker himself is a
big part of why both their Futures as
normal people have been completely
ruined and much like Joker's sidekick
Harley was sidelined Robin the Boy
Wonder was also omitted from this movie
to make the film's final showdown less
crowded as well and speaking of that
final showdown at Gotham's extremely
rundown Fair of the future when Batman
is looking for the Joker in this
miniature model of of Gotham City Batman
walks past a Warner brother's building
while the Joker stalks Batman wearing
the Chrysler Building on his head and
finally at the very end of the fight the
fantasm disappears with the joker
leaving the audience to assume that this
Angel of Death took him away in order to
take him out of this world forever but
the Joker would of course return to the
DC Animated Universe to the surprise of
absolutely everybody who watched this
movie however like I alluded to before
1996's Batman and Robin Adventures
annual shows us exact how the Joker
escaped would seem to be a near certain
death because when the fantasm and the
Joker disappeared in that puff of smoke
Andrea actually just brought Joker to a
nearby sewer however right before she's
about to give Joker the final blow to
send that psychopath to clown hell she
pauses for a second to remember Batman
asking her what Solace Vengeance would
bring to her unfortunately that pause is
all the Joker needed for one of his
explosions to free him from Andrea's
grasp leaving him to drift down the
sewers current to ruin some of somebody
else's family some other day because
that's the Joker way but anyways thank
you guys so much for watching this
breakdown of Batman mask of the fantasm
I freaking love this movie and I'm so
sad that Kevin Conroy is no longer with
us because that dude is an absolute
Legend he literally gave us the greatest
version of Batman that the world has
ever seen and the first ever Batman that
I was personally ever exposed to so yeah
rest in peace you absolute King Kevin
Conroy you are the man and no one will
be able to do it like you but yeah thank
you guys so much for watching this video
and special thanks to Paul Mr Kevin
spoilers himself for helping me out with
a number of Easter eggs in this film
that man is an absolute King but anyways
you can follow me at mastertainment on
Twitter or Instagram or YouTube or
wherever I am on the internet but most
importantly you can follow heavy
spoilers here on YouTube and do not
forget to hit that Bell to get
notifications for every time we upload a
video because we do that fairly often
and you don't want to miss out but yes
thanks again for watching you guys are
amazing and I'll see you guys next time
goodbye